my most awaited MacBook is finally about
to come out but some people are saying
that it's gonna be a disappointment so
in this video we're gonna talk about the
full specs we're going to talk about the
battery life the price and what is my
opinion about this machine and if it's
going to be worth buying it or if you
should wait for the M3 13-inch MacBook
Pro now I want to start out by letting
you guys know how we know that this is
going to come out now a while ago I made
a video talking about the one Mac that I
want but Apple doesn't want to give us
but here in 2023 I think that they just
didn't have a choice anymore and I'll
explain why now we've had info about
Apple working on a 15 inch air for a
long time now but then things got quiet
but recently things have gotten very
clear I want to give you guys the latest
in info and this month we have this leak
that the 15-inch MacBook Air components
are already underway that the production
is already started for this machine and
this is from Ross Young Who has the most
accurate uh track record in terms of his
leaks he is in the supply chain
specifically on the displays and pretty
much everything that he's mentioned has
been correct other than the name of the
iPhone se3 and if that's not clear
enough the 15-inch MacBook Air was also
spotted in app store developer Logs with
the M2 Chip and just days ago a Korean
news aggregator ux also said that the
15-inch is going to come with the M2
Chip now this guy was actually the first
person that leaked the notch coming to
the 14 and 16 inch Mac book Pros so it
is clear that it is a hundred percent
coming and it's coming soon we also have
some specs on it but what happened with
the leaks of the M3 chip coming in this
machine well I'm going to talk about
that in just a sec but first I've got to
talk about the perfect sidekick to any
MacBook the new geminos monitor for
mobile pixels featuring ergonomically
designed dual stack 24-inch monitors
with minimal gaps between them and very
minimal death space required thanks to
the built-in base that has extra ports
like USB A and C ports ethernet and two
SD card slots plus the monitor angles
can be quickly adjusted and pivoted to
match your preference and height of the
built-in 1080p webcam so check out the
geminos dual stack monitor using the
link down below now with these leaks of
the M3 chip coming in this machine that
was a dream come true me finally getting
a slim machine that is thin and light
and just really nicely designed with
magsafe and the PowerHouse of the M3
chip so what happened well first off we
know that Max sales were down a massive
40 percent in quarter one before that we
were down about 28 which was horrible
but people are not buying Max for a few
reasons now we made a whole video about
this which you can check out but what
happened with the M2 Chip is that they
were more expensive with the new M2
MacBook Air and the chip even though it
is better it wasn't that big of an
upgrade in the M1 MacBook Air was
available for a killer price so because
of that Apple ended up shutting down the
M2 Chip reduction for two months which
they have never ever done on any current
chip that was being made and then when
they relaunched that well they only
started making him at half the
production that they had before and
we've recently had info that Apple has a
crazy oversupply of this chip so much so
that they are gonna update the 24 inch
iMac and put in the M2 Chip in there
when previously they were gonna skip
that because it's not a crazy seller
anyways and wait for the M3 and even the
iPad Air that has the M1 chip they're
gonna upgrade that earlier because they
have so many chips now with a 15-inch
MacBook Air we are expecting a design to
be identical to the 13-inch MacBook Air
just scaled larger now I don't think
that's a bad thing at all because unlike
the M1 MacBook Air we have Max a built
in and then we have two Thunderbolt
ports as well and they are Thunderbolt 4
based so they are very powerful now in
terms of the performance there weren't
some leaks talking about the M2 Pro
being in this machine but that is just
absolutely not realistic even though I
would love to have the upgrade to be
able to click spend a couple hundred
bucks more even if that means that
you're going to get close to the price
of the 14-inch MacBook Pro I think that
would be awesome but then it's gonna
kill sales from that 14-inch MacBook Pro
so for Apple it makes sense to keep this
thing weaker which is why they are also
putting the M2 Chip in there instead of
an M3 chip now on top of that we got
info that tsmc is struggling to create
enough three nanometer chips for Apple
they're only at about a 55 success rate
for these chips and they don't even know
if they're going to have enough for the
upcoming iPhone 15 Pro and apple makes
way more money on the iPhones that's a
much better seller than on MacBooks
which actually sell less than iPads and
services and everything else so because
of that and because of limitation it
also makes sense to throw in these M2
chips that have an over Supply now we
also had in Apple Stores data the
specifications it's basically the same
thing as the 13-inch M2 MacBook Air so
you have eight gigs of RAM and you have
the bin version and then you can spend a
little bit more money and get the
unbined so because of that in looking at
Apple's current products they're putting
out the iPhone 14 plus they're trying to
give us more options more budget options
especially in these times where
everything is very expensive people have
less money this machine makes sense
because people would want to to buy it
for that larger screen that's my only
complaint about the M2 MacBook Air I
love the size I love the weight the
thinness just sometimes the extra screen
real estate would be really good
especially for productivity so because
of these limitations for this device it
makes the most sense to have it start
out at fourteen hundred dollars two
hundred dollars more than the regular
13-inch model and then of course with
that you're going to be able to spend
more money if you want to unbin it
that's another 100 bucks getting you up
to 1500 and then if you upgrade your RAM
and your SSD which I would suggest for
performance well there goes the price
tag and now you're at a 14 inch like ah
maybe I should spend a little bit more
money get the mini LED so because that
people are saying with this M2 Chip
which we personally called a stop Gap is
it still worth it well personally for me
I think that this machine being so thin
and so light and with the new design it
is more than powerful enough for most
people heck we still recommend the M1
MacBook Air and when we call the M2 a
stop Gap technically it is because if
you look at the performance of the M3
chip based on the leaks of the a17 and
how all the other chips
um stack together we have a full video
on this if you need more info it's going
to be more powerful than the bend M2 Pro
it's gonna be an insane ship so yes it
is a stop Gap and yes that is
disappointing to buy a brand new 15 inch
but you have to look at what you need
the machine for these Apple silicon
processors are very very fast
and they destroy the Intel chips that
were out before so if you don't need the
absolutely best performance which most
people don't it is still going to be an
excellent machine and I think the
trade-off getting a machine much earlier
and having the larger size I think it's
going to be killer especially with the
the efficiency of the M2 Chip and with
the larger battery now as far as battery
life I recently made a video covering
how to get the best battery life out of
your MacBook using low power mode and
using low power mode you can get insane
battery life with the 13-inch M2 MacBook
Air now the battery in this thing is
going to be a lot larger personally I
think it's going to be about 83 Watt
hours that's a lot that is 58 larger
than the 13 inch model now where do I
get this well I'm basing it off of
Apple's previous Max and how everything
stacked up so if we take a look at a 15
inch MacBook Pro it had an 83.5 watt
hour battery in that enclosure and yes
the MacBook Air will be slightly thinner
but it is also that new kind of squarish
design that has more room internally and
apple loves to max out their laptops to
put in the biggest battery that can so
the battery life is going to be
absolutely ridiculous and real world use
for simple scenarios where you're
emailing web browsing with that low
power mode with the M2 chips powerful
efficiency cores you're going to be able
to get 30 hours of battery life I mean
it sounds insane but check out my
battery life video for me to show you
how that even works and how that's even
possible so you guys can check out that
video right over there so personally I
do not think it's going to be a
disappointment I'm very excited for it
you guys let me know what you think down
in the comment section below and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you